how long have you been making music
uh
i was in
i was ending fifth grade i didn't have a
phone no i did have a phone i stole i i
forgot i had a phone and i downloaded
garageband and then i started [ __ ]
like i had some [ __ ] written and then
uh
i had some [ __ ] written then i spit it
on garageband then i found a beat after
and then i posted it and then people at
my school started hearing about it sixth
grade
like the end of fifth grade okay okay
and people was like just making like gas
and like making fun doing this doing
this you know and it was expected like i
i go back and i listen to some of my
music like all of my music is weak
there's no exception to it but like i
took it personal because i always felt
like okay you don't like it you're going
to like it soon like if you and even if
you don't like it you're going to be
forced to pay attention because if i'm
all over your screen you don't got no
choice but to pay attention because if
you see me here oh oh look i remember
him from fifth grade whoopty whoop like
if you see me
uh how do i how do i wear this how do i
work this it's
like if you don't [ __ ] with me
okay
but
you're not gonna get rid of me like i'm
gonna be around you know and i told
everybody like that laughed at me i was
like all right [ __ ] you i'm gonna go i'm
gonna do the and i started this [ __ ] all
on my own they like i some people i used
to [ __ ] with that i like i uh
like i would record at their house or
whatever but like there's nobody that
like i started like making music with
that i [ __ ] with now because
you know
enviousness and jealousy because like
when it when like everything started
popping like in like may of last year
when i posted it i was on tick tock and
i posted my song mafia and it went crazy
and now i like
some [ __ ] like this ain't never happened
before so
i was like i was excited
and i was like telling all my homies
about who i started the music [ __ ]
whether i was like hey bro my like my
tick tock hit like a hundred thousand
views like i got like ten thousand
followers like and they were happy for
you was the other way around huh yeah it
was just that they like
after the first time it was like okay i
see you blah blah blah blah and then
after a while there was like bruh stop
flexing on us stop bragging i said i'm
like bro y'all see what i had to come
from to get here right because i'm a
white rapper it's not like you you gotta
like it's it's hard to like
uh you're not just a white rapper you're
a 16 year old white rapper yeah but but
at this time i was a 15 14 year old
[ __ ] crazy